the thing about directing is time is
ticking and you got to wrangle the
actors
hi I'm glad you're here are you never
thought I'd hear those words come out of
your mouth so this season I'm directing
episode three and it came to be because
Larry called me and asked me if I was
interested in selecting one of the
episodes this year I'm with a bunch of
stiffs the food sucks the drinks aren't
strong enough in your hand is up my ass
it was really amazing seeing the whole
world of it because I got to hang out
with the crew some of the crew I I'd
really didn't know very well and then by
the end of the shoots like I'd rather be
hanging out at the camera track then at
crafty with
[Music]